good call to fans let's crack open the
honest trailer vault from the production
company behind break into electric
Boogaloo comes a Superman movie so bad
it'll likely kill the entire franchise
for 19 years stop Superman for the quest
for peace Christopher Reeve is back for
one last paycheck as Superman in one of
the corniest movies of the decade which
is saying a lot since this is the
eighties the name of the game is making
money watch as this mild-mannered dork
turns into this mild-mannered or I'd
like all the people back there to know
that our subway system is still the
safest and most reliable means of public
transportation we dwell in horror at the
return of mentally unstable actors
Margot Kidder
as she struggles to play Lois Lane he's
doing his best to make sure that it'll
be alright for the rest of them yeesh
and gene Hackman returning as Lex Luthor
and evil genius who can't pronounce the
word nuclear nuclear powered nuclear
strategist nuclear bomb nuclear warhead
nuclear me the quest for peace begins
when this dumb overdub kid I tell you
why dried insanity that would do some
good Santa Claus no Superman killed
Superman into collecting all of the
world's nuclear weapons that he'll stuff
into this big net and throw into the Sun
which somehow the UN is totally cool
with confused
just wait we're only getting started
watch his legs and ducky from pretty and
big easily cut Superman's indestructible
hair strap it onto a missile and launch
it into the Sun to inexplicably create
nuclear man destroy Superman now behold
the super sight of two grown men in
spandex going toe-to-toe in some of the
most poorly executed [ __ ] fights ever
put to celluloid
Wow this is bad this is really bad
heck was that
what is this space tag of nails really
come on you're Superman
do something
that looks terrible he scratched him
Superman lost from a scratch that made
no sense are we sure we want to release
this thing marvel that Superman's powers
that you know and love and stare in
wide-eyed disbelief at these new
completely made-up powers life
rebuilding the Great Wall of China with
his eyes lowering people with his mind
and helping this woman breathe in outer
space so if you thought this year's
predator and space balls look too
polished then we've got the summer film
for you filled with terrible blue screen
fake miniatures ridiculous oversized
props really really terrible glued
screen and the same flying shots used
over and over and over and over again
seriously these are all the same shot
you couldn't do one more take
that's that's lazy you guys starring
Captain America hat man desperately
seeking Superman Charlie Sheen Betty
Ford and Dolph Lundgren ish Superman IV
the quest for peace man this movies bad
at least it's not Marvel right those
guys will never figure out how to make
movies hey ever wanted an honest trailer
t-shirt no have you ever changed your
mind there's a link in the description
below I must break you
if you're gonna spew spew into this
weebles wobble but they don't fall down
It's Raining Men hallelujah the
Lannisters send their regards